hey what's up guys my name is Jonah
welcome back to my game engine series so
last time we added GLM and talked about
maths libraries in general for game
engines make sure you check out that
video if you haven't already and today
we're gonna be doing some I'm GUI
adjustments and fixes some new features
that will actually add to that and well
actually our implementation of I enjoyed
the way that we've kind of integrated it
in behavior will change and for the
better and this is like kind of I think
the last major set up that I kind of
want to do before we actually start
working on the renderer so that's the
direction where we're taking hazel I
just want to make sure that I am do is
ready to go for all of that because it's
really useful to have a good
implementation of that because it'll
help us a lot when we actually start
doing the render and we can tie in
various things to iron GUI as well as
have custom controls that will represent
data that's coming in like from the
renderer and all that stuff so it's
really important stuff and I really
can't wait to get all these exciting new
kind of features that I'm going into
hazel so first of all I want to thank
everyone who helps support the series on
patreon icon for slash the churner huge
thank you to everyone there because the
series just would not be here without
you guys so thank you so much for
supporting you get certain rewards such
as access to Hazel's development branch
which is where I've actually already
done all this stuff and much much more
in fact the render is basically written
in that branch I mean it's like all of
the lower-level systems all that stuff
there's a render command queue this
various kind of rendering technologies
already implemented in that branch
definitely check it check that out help
support the series and get access to
stuff like that
obviously stuff like the I'm GUI stuff
stuff that we're gonna do today has been
there for like over a month I think so
if you kind of want to go ahead and you
want to just not just see these videos
but actually get some get the source
code as it's being developed phase it'll
definitely check that out and you also
get videos like around a week early
usually so that's also another kind of
benefit that you get for helping to
support this series alright anyway what
are we doing today
so the way that we've integrated iron
GUI at the moment was and I talked a lot
about this in the iron GUI episode maybe
watch that again it's just so that you
get kind of an idea because you know
this is software engineering we change
direction we change our minds quite
often and I
like it's not like I have a game engine
ready to go on github and now suddenly
I've decided to make a series of every
step that I'd know we're developing this
together as we go along that's why I
made that video with the github issues
and all that stuff and how to kind of
submit pull requests which I haven't
even looked at in weeks by the way I
really need to get back on now but
anyway um because of all that like this
is a serious thing develop as we go
along which means that that's like I
might wake up one morning and be like
you know what that thing that we did a
few weeks ago that's rubbish let's scrap
it and this isn't really one of the
cases this like in a way maybe you might
see that it is because we are kind of
changing our minds a little bit on that
but ultimately I'm glad that we had that
initial implementation of iron GUI
because that kind of allowed me to show
you a way that we might want to actually
implement it ourselves but because of
these kind of new features that I'll
talk about in a minute to do with iron
GUI
it's just I think it's a lot easier for
us to just kind of do it a slightly
different way which is gonna be more
kind of to do with like less divergence
from that code because what we ended up
doing let's just jump jump across and
take a look and I'll give you guys a bit
of a refresher so and I'm giel a er what
we ended up doing was a lot of the stuff
that we did here was inspired right we
kind of hooked it up with hazel events
all of this stuff was kind of inspired
by what hazel I'm sorry what I'm glad is
so this you know this file I'm going up
in jail render other H which we kind of
you know implemented this is basically
you know one of their own files right
and what we've kind of done is instead
of kind of use the GL fw implementation
of iron GUI so if we actually have a
look at i'm going let me just collapse
hazel if we have a look at I am GUI I
think if we actually go to the things
probably not included here if I actually
go here and go to examples you know jail
fw which is here of in jail 3 you know
um
which is actually implemented here for
some reason whereas a jail of w so we
have urban jail 3 there's jelf w right
so all of this stuff right this kind of
stuff we kind of took from this file and
actually included into our own
goooal a a riot via like event
dispatching essentially so mouse press
you know we did this kind of stuff now
that's great but the problem is this is
becoming more and more complicated like
I am GUI is growing like for example the
features let's actually dial this back a
little bit and talk about the features
that we're gonna be like why we're doing
this I'm going and what we're actually
gonna gain from that so I'm good I'm go
away Lee has kind of focused on two
important very important in my opinion
kind of things to actually add to I
agree and that is docking and also
something called viewports so docking is
just being able to dock windows right
like if we have a look at Visual Studio
you know we can rip off tabs and dock
them into like any window we want like
here for example we can create this you
know if we have team Explorer here we
can like just dock this here or grab
that tab individually and like dock it
up here and you know we had this whole
docking thing that we can do right I am
GUI has actually added that true I am
GUI so that you can actually organize
your kind of window as like a dock space
and then in there you can have multiple
tabs you can dock them however you like
that's really important because one of
the things that I want to do for hazel
is have a level editor and I want that
to be kind of built into the wrong time
because we don't really have the
resources to build a full application
stack and every time that and this is
gonna make everything so much easier and
to tie into that as well viewports is
something that they've made which
basically enables you to grab a window
from I am GUI and drag it outside of
your primary kind of application window
and I'll actually kind of just
on-the-fly create a new window a new
rendering context and everything and
it'll act kind of like that window and
we'll see that at the end of today we'll
see all of that kind of working it's
probably gonna be a long episode anyway
um that those two features in my opinion
are like really help make iron go you
very viable for just we don't need any
other like UI kind of framework like WPF
you know WinForms QT whatever we don't
need any of that because we can just use
iron GUI and these two features make it
so much better so I'm really excited
about that but anyway because we have
those features in there fairly advanced
fashion especially like
being able to create windows on the fly
and all of that stuff I don't want to
imply on all that that's not what the
series is about right I don't want to
have to implement that and maintain it
because the docking branch of I am
guilty which is where all this stuff is
it hasn't actually been it hasn't been
merged into master yet it's still kind
of in development they might change
things as they go along so what I want
to do is just use their implementation
like they're I'm GUI gfw implementation
there or even gel renderer all of that
stuff like verbatim icon as it is
without any changes no divergence at all
just included in hazel and run it that
way we can easily imagine any changes
they make again going forward this isn't
gonna be about honor
I'm gooeys got an update let's spend a
day like maintaining that and updating
all of our code to do that nor you'll
just be like kind of just you know
drag-and-drop kind of edit works so
that's what I really want to do and
that's what we're gonna kind of do today
okay it's quite a large little project
there's a bunch of changes that we
actually have to make especially in I'm
Google area I actually did this I think
yesterday or the day before just in a
different kind of I cloned the
repository and did it again kind of
myself so we'll kind of take a look at
the diff between that I haven't done
anything I know you guys like live
coding so what I'll do is I'll take a
look at the diff has already done this
work I had to do it ahead of time
otherwise it would have just taken too
long in this video but we'll have a look
at the different we'll kind of merge it
in line by line and actually have a
we'll see what it will look like so I
will be copying and pasting code but
this kind of where I'm at right now the
Profi have opened just does not have any
of these changes we'll pull them in
manually so let's take a look at this
and yeah we'll see how we go ok so this
is all the kind of this is this is a
repository with absolutely nothing if we
just launch this right now so that you
guys see where we're at once it compiles
OK you'll see we have our kind of
standard I'm getting we can drive this
around obviously if we go outside you
can see the window does not go outside
or anything so this is in fact the kind
of based implementation that we had it's
the first thing I want to do is actually
take a look at github so what I have
here in my fork of I am GUI apart from
just master being which is the branch
level currently on there's also this
docking branch right now this exists in
the actual I am going repository right
docking here it is and this is actually
being worked on like
two days ago was the last command this
is actually being actively worked on
right so what I did is I added my pre
make file to like 15 days ago you can
see I added that pre make file here as
well it is pretty much the same images I
had to also add the pre make file to the
docking branch because we're actually
going to switch from using master to
docking so the first thing we need to do
then is actually open up a command
prompt and we're going to go and switch
that we have we have IM GUI as a gift
sub module but currently some master in
fact if we kind of go to it so hazel
bender I am doing if we do a status
you'll see that we're on master right
inside I am GUI and you know it's up to
date with origin master whatever we're
on the master branch when you just wish
to the docking branch so the way we do
that is very easy for a sub module we
just check out the docking branch right
and then we have to go up a directory
and if we do a status looks for those
status you'll see we have I'm doing with
new commits on tract content so what
we'll do is we'll just commit I'm sorry
we'll just add that I am GUI thing into
our kind of in to get right so now what
will actually happen is the fact that
we've switched branch to docking that'll
be now tracked and so in that case you
know we've basically done that so to
summarize to switch to get sub module to
a different commit or to a different
branch what you have to do is actually
go into that directory do a git checkout
and then commit the commit that
directory right okay cool I don't think
I'm guilty even needs to be in veteran
in version control date dot ini file but
anyway there's a bunch of things that we
can we'll probably have a maintenance
episode soon because I think that some
things does not right in the repository
anyway now that we've done that and
we've switched that branch docking that
should be ready to go right so we
actually have access to all of that so
now what we need to do is switch all of
our stuff to actually work with that
docking branch now here's the thing we
need two new files right if I open up
hazel and go sandbox yes the vendor for
example thing is ignored because it's
been anyway we won't talk about that out
so hazel vendor I'm GUI this is now on
the docking branch right so this has
inside examples you know we have
you know that open jail three file I
think that we now need to compile and
also what was the other one the jail of
w1 right these two files actually need
to now be compiled what I could do is I
could just add them to pre Meg and have
them to be compiled like that but I'm
actually not going to do that I'm
actually going to make a file inside
hazel that just includes them and
compiles them and I'm gonna call that
file I'll make sure that I'm I'm show
off as mode I'm gonna create that file
inside arm GUI I'll make a new item
it'll be a CPP file I'll call it I am
GUI build they'll say be babe okay and
then over here I'm actually going to
include all the files that I need to
actually build from I'm GUI okay so the
first thing I'll do is I'll include the
PCH file and then I'm going to actually
include all of our files that we want to
compile so from I'm GUI which is
examples we have the jail of w1 so the
CPP file not the H file right and then
also the opengl one so examples I am GUI
opengl 3.0 key okay so it's got like a
little bit of a unity built here now the
thing is this opengl 3 file needs some
kind of OpenGL header file so like a
loader as they call it weighs in glad so
what I'm gonna do is just define that
before we include it so just fine the
way using glad ok so now if we hit ctrl
f7 to compile this we should basically
get all of our symbols compiling here
you can see we do again there we go one
succeeded yeah we have the CIT secure no
warnings but should be defined in our
actual build file anyway but the point
is there we go succeeded it right so
this is now contains all of the symbols
that we need from those two files we're
just compiling them manually so that we
don't have to actually check them in
time GUI because again they might
there's something that I want to Hazel
to actually control so there we go I'm
giving a compiler when we have all the
additional stuff that we need for
docking and for the viewports things as
part of the docking branch now now we
can actually get rid of I'm gooey layer
basically or at least change it so that
it's not like what we have so if I open
up the changes that I've actually made
I'm gooey layer
the first thing I did was I got rid of a
lot of these things right we don't need
any of these events so let's go over
here and just delete all these events
right gone and we'll actually plate on
events on update doesn't really need to
exist we're going to replace it with
something called on I'm GUI render the
other thing that I really don't like
here I don't know how I wrote this code
but obviously these are overriding
virtual functions so I like to mark them
as virtual which is optional it's a
stylistic choice but more importantly
there really should be marked as
overwrite just to make it clear that
they're actually virtual functions that
were overriding I'm gonna introduce a
new function called on I am go around
awhile talk about a little bit later but
for now that's all we need so the CPP
file what has changed
so we're including this stuff instead of
that OpenGL renderer so let's go ahead
and just bump in those includes we don't
need this OpenGL renderer or file at all
so inside platform open GL we have I'm
gonna OpenGL renderer this was basically
a copy of this file right the opengl 3
files so we don't know we don't want to
need this so I'm gonna go over here and
just delete them make sure you delete
them of course from disk and now they're
gone
okay so we have nothing inside that
platform open jail folder that's the
first step then what we have to do is
well in this case I mean I've pretty
much copied what I've done is I pretty
much copied what I am GUI had inside I
think OpenGL 3 maybe they had like a
little bit of a docking example I think
it was this main file even maybe it just
had like you know a bunch of stuff that
they actually did so basically what I
did was I copied that I copied that and
put it over here so into our I'm going
kind of honest hash so I'll grab all of
this code that I've got here and that's
basically what's happening with the own
attach function these stuff would the
key map doesn't need to be done because
that is now gonna be done inside this
JFW file right which is over here so you
can see what's
yeah there we go there's the keymap
stuff so we don't need to worry about
that at all that's now kind of just part
of I am GUI the actual code that they've
written which is great well while I'm in
the CPP file form go away I'll just get
rid of all this stuff that we have okay
and then so on to unattach I'll just
paste in the code that I've copied okay
done now on detach I'm not sure if we
okay so we just want to do basically
shutdown stuff and destroy context on
detach and then inside okay and then the
other thing that I've done is I've added
two functions called a begin and end
right what begin void end so we'll just
add those and what that's gonna do and
the reason I've done that is because I
want layers to actually be able to do
their own I'm going rendering right all
I want them to do is be able to write
something like I'm going begin I'm going
end so that they can actually like begin
a new window and then just render a
control and all of that stuff and that's
also where that I am GUI render comes in
so because we want to enclose like
layers in that kind of functionality
where they can just easily render a
window we need to actually begin window
rendering and and window rendering and
what by beginning and window rendering I
mean I mean begin and end I'm GUI
red-brown so if we look at the code
that's actually even begin and end so
let's just I wish we could just look at
one of these files there anyway because
there's a lot of stuff that's changed
here I think doesn't matter we'll just
copy this so inside begin we just have
this stuff right which basically just
says begin a new frame so we'll just
write void I'm gooey layer begin oops
again this is the stuff that goes in
there so this is basically it used to be
a non update and show demo window but
what we're actually doing is this part
we want to be controlled by layers
themselves right so for example the game
layer whatever we have inside sandbox
that should be able to be like hey I
want to show and I want to show a window
so not if it is to actually be written
and that's the only
code that record that is required to be
written by our client we need to have
this and begin and this in end so that
we can put all of our stuff in between
and that's where that on iron glue
render function actually comes in so
you'll see this in practice in just a
minute we actually don't need anything
in on update so I'll get rid of that I'm
in fact we don't need an online safe
function so we'll get rid of that as
well
okay so inside here we will have our end
function fine GUI and the end function
has a few more things will so we'll grab
it and more importantly has actually got
something from it's actually got
something I think that was all of it
yeah it's actually got something from
the from the docking branch which is
this whole viewports enable thing and
you can see it it's got some shell of W
stuff that runs now clearly this is kind
of specific to OpenGL first of all
because we're doing open jail in it and
also jail of W but that's fine we'll
probably end up having a separate I'm
gooey layer for each platform because
you can see that's what I'm goo does
right they have an example for OpenGL
dev an example for Vulcan they have an
example for DirectX versions right
they've got all of that stuff we're just
going to use that code for that because
I'm GUI is so kind of nice piece I don't
want to abstract it out into its own
thing they should just be able to
control the code that way we don't have
to do any work which is of course the
preferred result because then we'll have
we'll never have any issues everything
will have no divergence at all from
their code everything will just be
theirs which is perfect okay cool
so anyway that's pretty much all we have
to do I will add that on I'm GUI render
thing but I have to add that to layer
okay so we're adding something new which
is gonna be virtual void on I am GUI
renderer okay on I'm Glee troll would be
another appropriate name there anyway
I'll take this I'll put this into here
as an override and what this will
actually do or what we're allowed to do
in this function is do any kind of I am
GUI rendering right so in other words
for this case let's just say we wanted
to draw that demo window we can just do
I'm going show
my window right and we'll make a little
static bull here starting bull show
equals true okay and we'll pass that in
so this is all we have to do right if we
wants to make a new window we can just
do I am we begin I am going and a large
you're like what we'll actually
demonstrate this in a minute but
basically we don't need to do any kind
of like new frame none of that stuff
because this will sit in between begin
and end and can be as you can see
written by any layer so that's pretty
cool and we'll see this in action in
just a minute okay cool
so that's that I think what else we have
to do so the other big changes that I'm
at a guess for to application were
actually added the I'm gooey layer as an
actual like explicit layer so this is
now no longer something that I want the
game to be able to control
so inside sandbox app we manually added
our gooey layer not I don't want that
anymore
I'm Google layers will be automatically
added by Hazel's runtime perhaps in
certain configurations like distribution
you might not want to use I'm gooey if
you've chosen to only use I'm going for
debug purposes so we will have some kind
of flag maybe they're just strips I'm
doing completely but I see I'm gooey as
being something that is quite intricate
to actually like it's quite intrinsic to
Hazel it will just be part of Hazel and
that's that you don't have to render
anything with it if you don't want to
obviously but it will just be hazel
central UI that hazel provides so
because of that I'm going to centralize
it
so inside application I'm going to make
a unique pointer which is going to be
i'm gooey layer and it's going to be out
I am gooey layer we're going to include
we're gonna have to include that
probably although it's not going red on
twitter anyway so include hazel / I am
gooey slime gooey layer over here will
make it so will say I'm Google IO equals
s 2d make unique just like that and then
what we'll actually do is render it so
over here will do I am going begin then
we have to go
through I'll do end as well since I'm
here but then we have to go through all
the layers and actually call on I'm go
here and up you can see that this is
gonna sit in between begin and end okay
now when we do actually write the
renderer like I've already done in the
hazel development branch which is
available for patrons will have to
actually do this entire code on the
render thread so hazel will have like a
multi-threaded kind of architecture
where the we have an update thread which
is kind of just the application thread
and also render thread which we have a
render queue what we submit every kind
of render command - so this whole chunk
will actually be executed on that render
thread eventually just so that you know
like an update for example will not and
on update is where you can submit things
for rendering but this whole thing will
actually be on the renderer because we
have raw radicals like right in there so
that is that but there we have this kind
of odd iron glue render so this should
just show if we run this right now
hopefully it should just show our kind
of demo window so let's just build this
I don't know if I've forgotten anything
I guess we'll see pretty quickly but if
I just build this hopefully it will
build you can see it has so let's just
hit f5 and see what happens
okay so we have abort has been cold if
we retry this okay well I actually I
just realized I forgot to add this to
the layer stack so that's pretty
annoying but I think that's it I don't
think that I forgot to do let me just
quickly check it's sandbox out we don't
have any I'm good cotton here do we know
okay good
the other thing I want with the check
out is this diff so application dot cpp
what do I do here I actually never did
add it to the layer stack that's
interesting and that's probably wrong as
well so what this should actually do and
I'm not even sure why we get that out of
them but what this definitely should do
is we should be adding it to the layer
stack because we won't obviously on
detachment how does that even work then
if we don't if we never add it to the
layer stack that's very suspicious
anyway so we'll do we'll do push overlay
oh and actually that brings me at this
point
we actually can't have this is a unique
point I'm not even sure how that code
that I wrote yesterday worked at all
but anyway we can't have this as a it
shouldn't be a unique point or a rule
now that I'm actually looking at this
because obviously order ship is
transferred to the layer stack so I'm
GUI layers now something that's part of
our layer stack which means that layer
stack the term is when it gets created
and later this has to be a roll pointer
there we go so let's hit f5 that's very
weird there that code that I wrote
yesterday because it definitely worked I
definitely tested it but not sure how
let's take a look at this okay so we
have well this is great oh and this
reminds me as well of something that we
have a little bit of an issue with the
actual layer stack someone pointed this
out there's a bug we keep track of the
layer insert iterator which isn't the
best thing to do because if the whole
collection gets moved in memory
this has to be invalidated and redone so
what a better way of doing this is
actually to have a layer kind of insert
index right which could just be like an
unsigned ian's right we can set this to
zero to begin with and then what happens
is whenever we have to do this we can
just basically set layer insert we can
use this kind of layer insert index plus
like sorry we can do M layers plus the
index so that way it's always from begin
all right so begin + the index is what
I'm trying to say just like that right
we're going to do this anymore
we also don't need to do this anymore
right so basically we're inserting this
like layers are always going to be
pushed at begin + that index and then
all we have to do is obviously since
we've just inserted a layer that layer
is set index gets incremented and then
here that layer is set index gets
decremented right so whatever we pop a
layer we reduce that whenever we add a
layer week
we increase that so for example if we
push a layer suddenly this is now one so
we push the next layer at position one
right whereas if we push an overlay that
gets pushed into like position two or
whatever this is still one so when we
push another layer a little bit it'll
get pushed in before that overlay right
so that basically just keeps a little
separation there but we don't need to
actually use an iterator for that just
an index and that'll be a lot better
because if we move or whatever if we
resize the vector and the iterator kind
of gets invalidated we don't need to
update it so if we hit f5 now maybe this
will work okay and look at that it's
already actually is spawned with the
window outside but you can see what we
can do now is we can grab this imq demo
window and just drag it like outside of
this like how cool is this right we can
just have that I'm going window outside
and then we can drag it back here and
everything is fine if we open like
another window so if I go to like
examples you know log for example you
just drag that outside right and there
we go we have multiple I'm glute windows
just floating around in space which is
really really cool
now the dock space is also or just
docking is another really cool thing so
if I go example dock space right this
whole window now is a dock space where I
can just like drag this in here you know
put my log down here and you can see
it's just like a normal application it's
kind of like let's have been something
else like console you know this kind of
becomes like a little and I'll dock this
maybe side by side this becomes like a
little almost a kind of like visual
studio or any kind of application who
uses docking right so that's really
really cool I really like this you can
see we can totally like to make a few
port maybe here like a people window and
that will kind of be our rendering and
we have like a little level editor like
set up pretty much immediately so this
is kind of this is really exciting
something that I really wanted to do and
obviously we can grab these windows and
drag them off outside of the window like
how cool is that right we can make you
can totally make a really cool
application with this now so that's kind
of the major features that I wanted to
add now I want to leave you guys with a
little bit of a homework assignment how
do we get I am Glu working here right so
I have obviously my void on
Renda which I could just like just put
in here right
just throw in here and now idea reticle
a should be able to do
I am GUI begin you know we'll call this
like test I should be able to type in
I'm doing text and you know write
something like hello world and then I'm
going end right to make my window now
obviously we need to include IM GUI
which we actually can't really do at the
moment so let's just include IM GUI
slash i'm gu h that's how i'd like to
include it in order to make this include
work we should actually go back into
hazel and edit the pre make file so that
we inside under sandbox which is here in
our include directories and we can
include hazel slash evander right we
should include all of our vendors stuff
so if I rerun pre make generate projects
ok cannot open and I'm GUI that is a
shame
why can't we generate that oh great more
problems that's what I just what I
wanted so this actually doesn't have we
must not have pulled so let's do get
full origin docking alright just to pull
the layers code which would include my
pre make file which I guess we didn't do
okay cool so now we have pre make 5 Lua
so if we run generate projects you can
see we generate them I'll reload all
this include should now work so if I can
control f7 to build this you can see it
builds fine right but if I try and
actually run it so I'll try and actually
like compile and Link it not just
compile it you can see I actually get
three linking errors right so this says
error on result of town symbol begin and
in text somehow they're not linking in
why use that so if we take a look at our
linking structure roughly we have I'm
GUI being built into a static library
and then being put into hazel which is a
DLL so it looks like those symbols
aren't actually being exported by our
DLL file which is hazel right that's a
little bit weird why is that happening
and that's where you guys come in to fix
all of this
so have a think as to why you think this
is happening again just to make it
really clear and help you guys out a
little bit bigger things we have our
static I'm GUI library all of those
symbols of course it's a static library
so all those symbols are being included
into the into the DLL file which is
hazel DLL so then now in my dot exe file
which is sandbox links against hazel why
are those iron GUI symbols not coming
through I want to know leave a comment
below see if you can find a solution I
of course already know the solution by
the way just see that's clear and
there's actually many solutions but I
already chosen the solution and that's
actually already in the I'm GUI sorry in
the hazel development branch that's
available for patrons they've done a
couple so that's the Cherno to support
series by the way huge thing was always
anyway I already got the solution there
but have a go see if you can figure it
out this is a really good exercise of
just how they put puzzle works as well
so definitely check that out and have a
thing and leave your solution in the
comments below if for those of you who
are right I'll pay them probably the top
comment but also I wanted to say maybe
if you're watching this video and not in
like the first hour or whatever have a
thing for yourself before you look at
the comments and see if you can figure
it out and obviously you guys next time
goodbye
[Music]
you
[Music]